I'm excited about this and I'm excited
about this everything else looks
terrible
this man's been Schwartz you guys on Ben
Schwartz he's about to come out with a
movie that he's in called the walk yeah
y'all know about the pumpkin spice latte
that y'all know about them we're gonna
taste tests all the different types of
pumpkin spice things and away we have
ice bomb it I feel like maybe we should
open with the pumpkin spice Kellogg's
mini wheats right yeah of course I feel
like I'm an Oliver never you did well
look at that look at that Wow already
first one just like will straight up one
could you not taste it do you want to
see what it feels like with that why did
you get spoons
we're just dipping in the milk the old
milk okay you don't know how breakfast
works I guess I'm gonna have to go like
soft and give it like a seven six that's
soft I'm gonna give this a seven I
enjoyed it okay I'm gonna give it a 6
already do you smell it
I smell no pumpkin pie I don't you oh
but it doesn't taste the problem is this
great peanut butter but there's a pump
if we were just doing a pumpkin or we
just ran on pumpkins I mean then it's
like a 1 or 2 I think right now you're
gonna give it a 2 I'm gonna give it a
zero four zero boys yeah what how you
gonna come in here with no pumpkin that
goes one through ten you measure the
roads you can crashing hey everybody get
inside here yeah I mean oh yeah right
that's real like so like ryokan paprika
you better go get some milk no I think
oh my uh that won't smell bad later
today right let me papa
you know I'm gonna give them I'm gonna
give him an 8 Wow that give this is up
okay so I like peeps very very wait what
do you not like beeps who like ready
shall we
there we go
we had the opposite we did the same move
and it's an opposite thing John Wilde
when you're thinking about peeps and who
think about our scale which is now
become famous yes one through ten
pumpkins join me go first please by the
way three uh I already gave out a zero
honestly it's a negative one to me
there's a little discussion second M&M
and then oh what's this over here
it's like if you took a [ __ ] then ran
around Central Park like an hour he's
like you want this Eminem out of an
[ __ ]
wait put that way why might you through
I don't like it is it okay just never
believe it it stays like whatever I'm
gonna give it a five you're all over the
place I don't trust you in anything
anymore we don't know anything about you
like peeps five for the M&M you're crazy
hundred spice latte what because you
know what ranking because you know we
don't know what numbers mean thread in
the peeps are they not any good I'll
give it up I'll give it up for who this
was like pumpkin spice you feel I feel
bad they look beautiful reading yeah I
did not even know I didn't know if I was
chewing or not I know if I was touching
anything this is one step below that so
I got to stick with one cuz I know what
one two ten means what do you give it
here comes a negative you know I'm gonna
give it a one because it low here's the
thing the peeps taste disgusting these
at least just taste like marshmallow
peep oh wow I'll just nibble on it just
really this is not bad I mean listen you
never want to chew it in real life like
if you were going to go on a date with a
guy or girl I wouldn't pop this in the
memo no who wants like Moyes we can feel
sound good now it is the most pumpkin
spice thing we go by the way it really
turns a Pullman fire each stick has
wonderful pumpkin suppose you have a
someone else actually beef but in 18min
it's like Willy Wonka's yes exactly
um I'm going to give it ready I don't
know if I'm right at nine out of ten
Oh